nature of Midnight Madness is one solves
a puzzle the answer that puzzle reveals
a location one goes to that location
where you receive the next puzzle and
then you solve it in turn we have raised
over 3.1 million dollars today for poor
people in New York
hailing all the way from England the
imitation gamers my name Tom Howard I'm
from council capital or I'm a partner
and on the team today I'm the team
captain we're very used to get used to
working together in an office
environment but we're not so much used
to scoring around New York at three in
the morning Dino 3pm a minute before
sunset good luck and see you at the
finish line this was with the game room
through we're between the son of a let's
just wait more than or we've got to get
into the Museum of the American Indian
at temperature yeah
listen carefully if something important
to tell you that will prove invaluable
along your journey tonight you'll need
me and my colleagues many times along
your path and every time you will see us
that was something very important to
learn
we should told me it was a small little
scavenger saying that he needed some
help with he lied totally uh and I got
sucked in after the first year of doing
it this is a baby we started 10 months
ago and we have we are giving birth
while Lindsay says it's like giving
birth and I know the agony and I know
exactly what she's talking about it is
one the most dumb it's been wrong the
most meaningful experiences either
you
I very much wanted to create a Sleep No
More that was outside all night where
you really are sleeping it was really
exhilarating to to finally get here
how do you hear
did you say hi said but it was a full
16-ounce is get that jacket that was a
tiring exhausting frustrating annoying
fantastic really fun